But yeah, no, it was it was just like never ending like digital
war. Like you could like that you could tell they all think that
they're like these digital foot soldiers.
>> I got to say a lot a lot of slurs. Like I mean slurs,
you guys. Uh the bad ones, like the very very bad ones. Lot of
slurs. Yeah, I I do agree that criticism of you Hutch will feel
like targeted harassment because you are a narcissist.
>> Maybe you want to check out that Ogre Boy video that
Hutch put out. I thought maybe that might be funny.
Let me see. Let me see. Here's where we arrive at something that
I want to focus on. Ogre Boy, I know you're watching this, buddy.
Pay attention to this part, okay? There were people coming into
the chat on Livin' Learn spamming stuff about my dead sister.
And uh ladies and gentlemen, we got them. Oh my god. This was
when they were still putting the chat on the Livin' Learn and
someone was spamming and they were jumping between different
>> Mhm. Immediately I'm like, this is [__]
up. And then I went over to the the alleged snark server and
I was like, this better not be any of you people. Like like don't
even tell me that it's one of you. Come on, bud. You know I have
the logs and I can
Uh then show the logs of anybody saying they were doing that?
Does he Does he show the logs here or
he's going to stand on this and say, oh you know I have the logs?
I can read the Like that's very different than somebody
who is saying that [__] Who is Perry? If Perry was
right? But I'm pretty sure nobody's done that. That's uh that's
a no no no no no no no. >> whole conversation. Like you
know that. Why are you lying about this? Not true. He did not
say that. And I had like three people immediately respond like,
I'm not doing it. It's not any of us. And then that was it. Also
not true.
And by the time I looked back cuz I was on Also not true.
Oh, okay. Then can Hutch show that? My phone, by the time I looked
back, they did they'd already banned the person and it had stopped.
Also not true. Everything about that is a lie. To my knowledge,
it wasn't coming from anybody that I was aware of. Just like
bald-faced lie. But the way that you really own these people
is like go out in your communities, go volunteer at a soup kitchen.
There's one more person that I want to Never mind. [clears throat]
in terms of how they're reacting to this story and it's just
it's too good. I know Listen, I'm violating a policy. I'm temporarily
violating a policy that I've had for for months. We're going
to temporarily pause the no ogre boy policy cuz he
When have you ever When has he ever held Hutch, you don't have
the self-discipline to hold to any policy. Just don't don't make
policies, man. You, Destiny, the same guy. You don't have the
self-discipline to maintain anything you say like that. Why Why
even try it? He was spending a little bit of time talking about
this on his stream and I would like to unpack it with you guys
cuz I did catch a few minutes of it and boy are there some doozies.
It's good. It's real good. by anyone in any server. He thinks
this is funny. They all think this is essentially funny. It's
just that Destiny is trying to paint this is this is something
that's affecting his court case. He's trying to stretch this
out. He's trying to like pull the timeline backwards far enough
to try to suggest that the people in this server have something
to do with what is going on with like his court case, with a
lot of these >> commentary on that from Hutch. He needs
a new victor. He needs a new aggressor to point at. Did he get
a Oh. Is that true?
Yeah. [clears throat] Is that true? Wou- Would you even Would
Hutch even entertain the possibility that that could be true?
Like will he actually entertain it or is he going to totally
fake entertaining it? He's like
He's like a duplicitous compromised
I think it's just the fake part. We'll see. Maybe it's probably
just the fake part, but maybe. True.
Genuinely, is that true? Has he Has Destiny been referring to
the Snark Discord as something that has to do with his court
case? I haven't heard that. Have you guys heard
Has he not implied that that Discord like proves something about
me or somebody else to do with his court case? Has he not done
that? >> heard that? Does anyone know what he's talking
about? He has discussed his deposition on stream, but that's
not what I'm saying. He's saying that Oger boy is saying that
the the Discord the Destiny is framing it as as the the Discord
is like Oh, yeah. He said that they're sending the people in
that Discord are sending arguments to opposing counsel.
That's what he said.
with his court case or something like No, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, he has Oh, no, no, no, but Destiny
has said that the people in that Discord are sending arguments
to opposing counsel, right? And he can prove that. Did he not
say this? Almost like I think he said this verbatim.
May Well, we'd have to find the exact wording, but he said something
very much like this. like that. Uh some actors involved in both.
He's claimed that J Stalk and some of these other people have
been feeding information to Pixie's defense. Oh, I see. All of
the things that have happened to me are because of these people.
That's what he's doing. So, uh but we'll get to that. Now, meanwhile,
everyone else I don't think that's true. I think that's overstating
it just a little bit. while everyone else So, uh but we'll get
to that. Now,
meanwhile, everyone else I don't think that's true. I think that's
overstating it just a little bit. Wait, why is this 480p?
This is basically a new >> overstating it? Hold on. What
is overstating it? >> these people. That's what he's doing.
I see. All of the things that have happened to me are because
of these people. That's what he's doing. So, uh but we'll get
to that. Now, That is absolutely what he's doing, and Hutch is
like Like directionally, that's 100% what he's doing. Come on,
man. Come man. >> I don't think that's true. I think that's
overstating it just a little bit. None of us can like let's be
honest about what this is. Let's let's really dive in here.
None of us feel like we can do anything, whether it's a Democrat
or a Republican administration, to actually change the course
of what's going on. Even if we voted super duper hard, all you
can do is vote hard, participate in your communities,
Dude, no no argument, no conversation. He just makes faces. This
just makes faces. It's all he can do. No argument, no content,
no nothing.
Right? Hey, Hutch. He's He's trying to make an argument about
how much you could contribute to politics as somebody who's a
commentator. Do you have any thoughts on that or are you just
going to make stupid faces? Try to do advocacy and then hope
for the best and hope that maybe even if it's This person >> Sam
Seder talked about why he was okay, even though he's not an anarco-communist,
why he worked with an anarco-communist.
Because he wants a a broad left.
He just admitted that he doesn't think individuals can impact
>> Oh, I I thought he was going to make his own argument.
He's actually just reading somebody else's argument. Okay. So,
he sits back and he makes faces. He waits for a chatter to make
his arguments for him so he can read them and go, "Oh, yeah,
baby. Oh, yeah, maybe. Maybe that's the way it is." act our government.
This is obviously an outlet to give him the feeling of control
over his Well, yeah, I think he's very explicitly like laying
this out. But also like I do tell my chat that they should you
know, some people should tamp down their expectations. Like
I I don't think it's reasonable
to think that like medical Medicare for all is like a good example
of this. Like that policy
is just nowhere near the kind of support that it needs in Congress
to pass. Like a some kind of single-payer policy. Public Does
this not So, I'd have to look at the polling on this. I'm I'm
unaware of what the policy is. Regardless, it doesn't mean you
can't push for the policy. Doesn't mean it's like stupid to push
for the policy,
You do need the right story to tell around it. You could run
on it. Right? Like I'm trying to think, there are probably some
other policies that wouldn't have like broad support if you just
polled with with just them laid out the way they are, right?
Anyway, we keep >> Option, yes, but not Medicare for all.
We're just not close to that. And so, for those people, I do
say, if you're going into a new administration, like if you went
into the Biden administration,
he's sworn in in January 2021, and and you're going in there
thinking like, "Oh, maybe we can get single payer." And then
that didn't happen, and then you're pissed about that. You caused
that. You inserted your own unrealistic expectations of things,
and because those things didn't happen, you're pissed, but you
did that to yourself. Like you caused that anger by going into
something with wildly unrealistic
expectations. And this is a principle that can apply to every
part of your life. This is a universal principle. You should
check your expectations in your own personal life, maybe with
your career,
with your partner. Okay.
That's like your internal expectations can be lower. You don't
need to not push for aspirational things, right? Like I'm totally
fine with yeah, with like lowering Like that's a good path to
personal happiness. I don't know if that's a good path to political
change, right? Like if if black people are slaves and you're
just telling them like, "Hey, maybe just like we could give you
like an hour off each day or something."
Right? It's It's like, dude, there's probably like a fundamental
injustice going on here. Not that I think there's a similar level
of injustice happening in American society right now. It's just
obvious that
sometimes it's not enough. Sometimes you should message more
aggressively.
I don't think messaging You shouldn't
You shouldn't have discipline in what you're willing to push
for. You should have discipline in what you're expecting personally,
by my opinion. Your husband, your wife, your kids, your friends,
your family, like if you start imposing your expectations on
other people and then they don't meet them and then you cop a
resentment over that, they didn't do that, you did. Like you
don't accept that they are the way that they are.
I wish it wasn't Hutch so transparently just giving us the things
his therapist has told him. You know what I mean? Like I just
Unfortunately, that's like a complex thought that is actually
valid and intelligent. And so I know that that's just him reiterating
what his therapist has told him. Like I know he didn't come up
with that. Whenever Hutch gives you a valid like complex intelligent
thought, you can automatically go, "Oh, who'd you get that one
from?" Or you don't accept that things are the way that they
are. And so you're making yourself angry. I mean like so I say
stuff like something like this, which, you know, I think that
is just such a like an obvious thing that people should think
about. But very often times people like AugurBoy will will
will describe that kind of idea as
me saying better things are not
But I'm not saying that. I'm saying better things are possible.
I'm saying better things happen all the time. A lot of better
things happened when Biden was president. You should want better
things. You should ask your politicians to do better things,
to make better decisions, and create better is not what Dude,
rhetoric is not How many times do you have to get absolutely
obliterated by the orange liar that prompt that
for you to go, "Oh, maybe some soaring rhetoric would be appropriate."
Like how many times? How many times you got to get by this orange
liar before you're like, "Oh, maybe I could like, you know, push
for something bigger and then we'll try to do the best we can
and we'll see what happens."
We never thought about that, have we? No, just get keep getting
asked by the orange the the fat orange man. Okay. better outcomes.
Like of course I believe in that. But, you know,
Apparently, this was all projection on his part because he thinks
that you're basically just like Uh I do like this Marty FC. He
calls it reasonable expectations but he's actually describing
cynicism and giving up. Most people who advocate for more radical
ideas already know the probability of success is low. That doesn't
mean you don't try. Yeah, exactly. There's a saying that everybody
knows you shoot for the star you shoot for the moon you land
amongst the stars, right? As in you should have aggressive targets
and you should push for them understanding that they're aggressive
targets, right? They're your North Star and if basically you
just want a target where if you get somewhere like halfway the
world's better.
There you go. Why is my
powerless to influence anything. That's what he's saying here.
So And he wants to try to move the needle and he thinks that
like the things he wants to see we might not get there in his
lifetime but he wants to try cuz that's what you need to do.
So we don't think that we can affect anything really in our government
but you want some kind of catharsis.
And if I don't think that. I think you can affect your government.
[laughter] I think I think you can you know accomplish a lot
of things. I think you can create movements that lead to like
very real change.
Is he not just basically saying he wants an acknowledgement from
people in power that like this is important pushing these directions
are important? That's depressing to hear. >> go back and
listen to Oger Boy without the audio. >> This is good advice
for life but not for
You should put reasonable expectations on people you bring into
power and disown them if they don't fulfill reasonable is the
key part. Well, that's what I'm saying. You're making my point.
That's my point. You you should be reasonable. You can be aspirational
and and you can push for things that maybe you suspect are not
possible in the short term with the hopes that maybe you can
find a middle ground that's like >> What is this? Why did
Why did I get sent this timestamp?
It sounds like a joke but I'm not even kidding, right? Like Here's
my unironic advice for people that are getting into American
politics, okay? Expect less.
Wow, you did it for me. Scale your
down. This is unironically how you just let fascists with actual
soaring rhetoric take over your country. Don't listen to this
bald he doesn't know how to convince anybody of anything. The
only audience he has is because he's beholden to other people.
>> Closer to your goal like all that's fine, but if you're
going into an election thinking that like literally everything
is on the table and then when when the biggest
boldest parts of your policy platform, your preferred platform,
when those things don't happen and if you get really pissed it's
like well you did that. You did that to yourself. You did that.
It wasn't Biden who, you know, like caused this anger with if
you went into Biden's presidency thinking he could do like the
New Deal 2.0 with a 50/50 Senate, well you did that to yourself,
man.
That's something that they teach you a lot in recovery spaces.
Like resentments are a big part of Dude, I'm so dude, it's so
[__] up that this guy is like a transparent book.
It's so [__] up. Now like I'm telling you the expectation
thing that's just transparently from his therapist, yes, his
counselor, yes. I it's so [__] man. I don't
I want to be wrong about this guy one time. Do you know what
I mean? On a personal level. I could be wrong with the direction
he's going with an argument. He doesn't have a very linear thought
process to me, but in terms of what he's describing himself or
what he
and recovery like Oh, sorry, in a personal way. Sobriety, Alcoholics
Narcotics Anonymous, a big part of that program, of those programs
are unpacking your resentments. You one of the steps is you you're
literally writing down like everyone and everything that you
have a resentment towards.
And then ultimately what you learn with the help of a sponsor
is that for many of these things you're causing that pain yourself.
And then you're using that pain to
justify drinking or doing substances.
And so it's just like self-perpetuating
Of causing your own pain and then and then you're running to
substances to numb the pain. So, Hutch would rather have like
totally morally reprehensible people around him who go, "Hutch,
you're really smart and valid." Right? Hutch would love Hitler
over his mom if his mom was mean to him and Hitler went, "Hutch,
you're you're smart and valid." Right? Like that's I'm obviously
being a little extreme, but that is who Hutch is. Hutch would
much rather have somebody who's like kind to him and tells him
he's doing a good job than anybody who's honest with him and
anybody who is like real with him and helps him improve. That
is who Hutch is. Fundamentally at its core. Ogerboy right now,
trying to make arguments, has always engaged has always engaged
with Hutch, has always directly engaged with the arguments, right?
But now Ogerboy's being a little bit mean and Hutch is like,
"Oh, you're being mean? That means you're wrong." No, it doesn't,
Hutch. It turns out there are ways that people could disagree
with you or think you're a a [__] and be correct.
Many ways. I yap, I play videos, I snark on these sons of and
by that I mean just be critical. That's snark is the new critical.
And then that's it. I take snark to mean like
targeted harassment, you know? Yeah, cuz Yeah, I I know that
you take you take criticism as targeted harassment.
That's what you do.
Nobody started calling this snarking until you guys started crying
about it. We were just being critical the whole time. Being critical
with a comma comical and and negative lens or sorry, how should
I put it? Vitriolic lens, right? But it is comedy. The criticisms
are real. You just can't disambiguate the criticisms from the
like mean commentary, the mean jokes around it because you have
a you're a tiny man. You have a large ego and you're a tiny man.
You can't handle it.
So, like you could say, "Oh, well, I take it to be targeted harassment."
Yeah, I I do agree that criticism of you, Hutch, will feel like
targeted harassment because you are a narcissist. I can't wait
for the Snarker files. Oh, I'm sure they're coming. I'm sure
they're come I'm sure they'll be made public at some point. This
was a Dude, I'm I'm actually confident that Hutch doesn't realize
that he doesn't know. He goes, "I have the logs. You guys are
I actually think he's just lying. When when Ogerboy says, "No,
no, no, I asked if anybody did it and a bunch of people said,
'No.'" Right? I feel like Hutch doesn't know that the logs are
there to show this. Like he just has no idea. You know what I'm
saying? Like he has no clue that's the case.
A 24/7
surveillance operation.
Get over your self. That's crazy.
That's crazy.
It's true. I mean, listen, there's a bit of hyperbole here. They
were focused Like they watch the content you broadcast as a part
of your job. Like I have a 20 If I watch HBO for a couple hours
in the evening, I have a 24/7 surveillance operation on HBO?
Are you out of your mind? Don, like a lot of people. It wasn't
just me and I was not I was not even close to the the amount
of attention that that people like um Ethan and Destiny got,
but they were the point was like there was always someone like
chatting in the Discord. Like there was all there was just just
a never-ending conversation and they're all like targeting this
creator and that creator and this creator and that creator and
Okay, differentiate this from any Discord that's made around
content creators or content creation.
There's always somebody chatting in the Discord. They're always
watching
Y- Yeah. Again, um DGG chat's my favorite comparison. It's like
Tell me when DGG chat doesn't have a stream on. They always do.
Of course they do.
Like what are we talking about? What are we doing here?
Oh, that's a question for Och. Can you differentiate any of your
criticisms from the DGG community?
Nah, there were like there were like sometimes where they were
like more focused on me than other times and but uh but yeah,
no, it was it was just like
like digital war. Like you could like that you could tell they
all think that they're like these digital foot soldiers. No,
those are the other team. That's the other team. You know, fighting
for Hasan [__] and against these
like evil
uh liberals and Destiny orbiters and uh Zionists and uh it's
basically exactly what you would imagine. Why not just put your
logs out that show anything you're saying?
Based on their behavior. Just just just imagine what that would
look like in a Discord server. And yeah, it probably looks exactly
like that. Okay, first of all, you don't stream 24/7. What do
you
What do you mean? And He really took me literally on that >> Okay.
Oh, no. If somebody says I've been surveilled 24/7
and you don't know them, what does that sound like to you? What
does that sound like they're saying? We have had a strictly enforced
no ogre boy policy for several months now. I'm breaking it today
because this video is incredible. But I'll go on and show you
the number of times that he without me even mentioning it, that
he brings me up on his stream. He wanted in December, he was
talking out of the blue without me knowing it because Filmon's
always like 2 weeks behind.
>> He turned around and was like
What is Filmon by the way? What is that? Some kind of transcription
service? What What is this? We should bring Is he transcribing
all of my streams and then control F'ing for ogre boy? Is that
what is happening? Of course You You know what you could do?
Hold on. How hard is it to open a tab and go Filmon?
Oh, Filmot. Oh. Search within YouTube subtitles, captions, and
transcripts.
Why would you think you have to even do anything? Like literally,
you could just search this stuff. Like Hutch's has been on there
for like years now.
Since the site opened. Like I It's so weird that he thinks this
is the case. >> it is.
Why am I even questioning that? Obviously, yes. Jesus Christ.
Ogre boy What What Filmot does is it search It basically downloads
the transcripts for all the videos on a channel. And it will
index them so you could search them in aggregate, right?
That's basically what Hutch But Hutch doesn't understand that.
Right? So, he thinks people are watching all of his streams,
all of his old content to find old moments. He doesn't understand
there's a website that's indexed his entire channel with nobody
doing anything, nobody doing anything special, right? But they've
indexed his entire channel, all the transcripts from it, and
you can just search.
So, he just doesn't know any of this. So, he's coming on stream,
uh very much like his political takes. Completely uninformed.
Talking out of his ass, very confidently, making stupid faces
when other people say [__] when they actually have
information.
And he's embarrassing himself.
Just a classic everyday Hutch stream, >> You know, and
that'll be content. He is your Joker. He lost all his friends
and wants your proximity. This is, you know, it is like a Joker
origin story, and this is the
Now I feel like I'm being mean. Why do I Why do I Why do I do
this? Why do I do
Why Why Why do I do this? I am a nice person. I I swear to you,
I'm a nice person. Of all the origin stories of like an anti-fan.
Absolutely not. You're like a whiny piece of [__]
Total cry bully.
You're not a good person.
Pisco's a good person.
Pisco's standing up for you, and even when you came in, kind
of steered him in a conversation. Even when you did that, he
didn't go, "Oh, you, Hutch." Right? He went, "Oh, I didn't realize.
I'm going to fix this for you, Hutch." Like Hutch did not reciprocate.
Hutch would refuse to reciprocate. His entire mod staff let Pesco
get trashed for their entire argument.
He never once went, "Oh guys, be nice to Pesco." Even though
he says that, he's just lying. It's all there on the tape, Hutch.
Why do you lie? Don't lie. I'm pretty sure I don't want to get
into like what kind of behavior this this like transparent pathological
lying is, but it's not good.
This is definitely the saddest one that I've ever heard in my
life. It sounds like he had a dedicated a dedicated group of
friends that he played a video game with. And then come to find
out it wasn't a real friendship because he realized
they didn't they didn't really like him. They just liked playing
the game.
And so then there was like an emptiness inside of This every
friendship, by the way. This is like 99.9% of your friendships.
You're a an adult you realize this. That like the reason you
have best friends in like in school, in primary school, in middle
school, in elementary school, uh well, sorry, high school I meant.
Um the reason you have these friends cuz you're together all
the time, right? Like proximity is what puts you together. It
takes a lot of concerted effort to maintain friendships over
It just does.
I don't know. Does Hutch not realize
I don't know I don't know how you would fail to realize that,
to be honest with you. with him. Like he fills with his searing
hatred of me. I just don't I just don't know what to do with
that. That that's But
Hold on. Actually, why am I saying it? I want to drive the point
home. Here. Here. Here. Here. Hold on. Let's take a walk down
memory lane for a moment here, shall we? Because I want to set
the tone. He's trying to make it out
This is a This was a star surveillance operation.
What am I even looking at? belmont.com
search
ogre boy. Does he have some kind of an automated website? I'm
assuming that's what this is, where you automate to like monitor
people's streams? Or is this just monitoring everyone's streams?
I don't even know what I'm looking at here. Search within YouTube
subtitles, captions, and and transcripts. And he's just search
it's just a broad search. It searches like the whole internet.
He's like looking so desperately
>> to search that it's actually shocking. Oh my god, a
website exists on the internet
where you can search me?
Oh my god. Dude, he's like the guy from
Oh my god.
They're eating me, and then they're going to eat her. Oh my god.
Dude. Some kind of an automated website? I'm assuming that's
what this is, where you automate to like Oh, you're right. You're
right. You're right. My bad. >> monitor people's streams?
Or is this just monitoring everyone's streams? I don't even know
what I'm looking at here. Search within YouTube subtitles, captions,
and and transcripts. And he's just search it's just a broad search.
It searches like the whole internet.
He's just He doesn't even like
It basically like is you're not downloading anything to your
computer. And for Hutch's channel, as far as Ogerboy's concerned,
Hutch's channel's just been indexed for a long time. This is
the funny thing. It's like once all of this is explained, you
understand that Hutch's whole thing about being surveilled 24/7
entirely falls apart the moment he doesn't understand what Film
Mod is.
So, what Hutch thought was happening
is Hutch thought people were watching all of his old videos,
everything he's ever done, to try to find anything they could
use in a video against him. He doesn't realize that like so,
by the way, everybody in DGG, everybody who's on the side, this
utter
This fantastic
[__] has
come into this video. He's trying to tell you that these people
are stalking me. They're finding videos from like 10 years ago.
Oh my god. And he is unaware that you could just search the transcripts.
He is a totally unreliable person. He is totally out of his depth
trying to talk about this. And he's basically lying to slander
other people to create a permission structure to dox them. So,
thank you, Hutch, for coming into this whole situation, ignorant
like you normally do, and causing harm like you normally do,
you bald
searching the whole internet.
I'm being a little mean right now, but I think it'll make sense
here in a minute. He doesn't stream on Saturdays. What is he
doing? What is he doing? You don't have to be this hyper bro.
Hold on. We have to just Hold on. He's been mentioning me just
as much as anything else. What do we call this? Like weaponized
ignorance or weaponized stupidity? Like taking me literally and
being like, "What do you mean we monitor you 24/7? You don't
even stream on Saturdays." Like what is this? Like weaponized
stupidity? No sick day. There's literally nothing wrong with
watching Hutch's stream. Again, just making [__]
up. >> days 7 days a week. He doesn't stream on Saturdays.
What is he doing?
What is he doing? You don't have to be this hyperbolic, you shing
my ass. Oh, so he knows it's hyperbole, and he's like laughing
at you for being a whiny [__]
He identified that that's the criticism criticism, Hutch, that
you're a whiny
every move. I did $20,000. I did, yes.
You know, I thought
No, he didn't.
No, that's a meme.
And I'm so bummed that he figured out that I was joking. Go off.
You guys might think I'm being mean, but here's where we arrive
at something that I want to focus on. Oger boy, I I you're watching
this, buddy.
Pay attention to this part, okay? We figured out where all of
the, you know, there were people coming into the chat. This is
just a total lie, by the way. You know, everything he's going
to say right here, total lie. Post the logs, liar. Post the logs,
liar. Post the logs, liar. You're a liar, Hutch. Hutch, hey Hutch.
You're lying scum. Post the logs, man. Post the logs right now.
on live and learn, spamming stuff about my dead sister. And uh
ladies and gentlemen, we got him. So, we know where that came
from. Um okay, first of all, I'm going to touch on this one for
a moment. Please do. I'm all ears. Chance Seal Okay already let
it out of the bag. He admitted that the server existed. They've
been posting uh thumbnails and [__] of like I said
the server existed like weeks ago, by the way. I literally said,
of course I have a Discord. Of course I have a clipping Discord.
Are you out of your [__] mind?
Why would you not?
Like I think even Ethan Again, all of this, Hutch doesn't understand
this, that nobody cares about his dead sister, right? Like nobody
who's posting about it cares about his dead sister. They care
about an effective ecosystem
that is countering their messaging,
propaganda. They hate it. They hate having to show up and actually
have to do work. And so, they're trying to turn it into an existential
fight, right?
It's not. We're not going anywhere. We're totally going to stay
in a business with all the [__] that we've done in
that Discord, right? If adjustments have to be made, like I've
I've looked through what I can look through. If adjustments have
to be made, if punishments have to be dealt out, that'll happen.
But, that Discord is not going anywhere. This isn't an existential
fight for us. We know that we act correct 99.9% of the time,
and the 0.1% that you're going to try to pull out and turn into
something is going to totally blow up in your face. It will be
obvious that you don't hold any of these standards. It will be
obvious that you don't actually care about this, and that all
you're trying to do is shut the server down, which is never going
to happen. And Klein put it in a story
uh that like, oh, I'm coming to find out that there's a server.
And oh, it's got a skull with a CPS etched into the forehead
for the
the logo, the Discord server. I wonder what's in there. I remember
it because I was at the gym. Mhm. And I saw in the combined This
was when they were still putting the chat on the live and learn
and someone was spamming and they were jumping between different
channels. >> What can you do? >> Immediately, I'm
like, this is stop.
And I hadn't been in that Discord server for very long. And the
I did two things right off the rip because I saw that people
in the the combined chats were like, this is probably Ogerboy
doing it. It's like
And I messaged Pisco immediately and I go, I'm at the gym. I'm
not That's not me. I'm not [__] doing it. And then
I went over to the the alleged snark server and I was like, this
better not be any of you people. Like Like don't even [__]
tell me that it's one of you. Come on, bud. You like you know
you know I have You know I have the logs and I can I can read
the whole conversation. Like you know that. [__]
doing it. And then I went over to the the alleged snark server
and I was like, this better not be any of you people. Like Like
don't even tell me that it's one of you. Come on, bud. You like
you know you know I have You know I have the logs and I can I
can read the whole conversation. Like Okay, show us the whole
conversation, Hutch. Reproduce the whole conversation, Hutch.
Show me the
Show me the conversation.
Wait, just for this part. You're making this allegation. Show
me the conversation for this part that you have, you disgusting,
lying
sack of [__] Post the logs. Show me that you're not
engaging.
I'm going to hold off. I'm going to hold off. I have to hold
back. Show me the logs, liar.
Liar. Liar. Show me the logs. >> Like you know that. Why
are you lying about this?
He's just lying about this. No proof, logs? Let's go, swamp turtle.
Let's go. Didn't happen.
Not accurate. Not true. He did not say
And I have Oh, is he just saying that Ogerboy asked if people
were saying it there? There's no Wait, that's even worse. That's
actually so much worse, isn't it?
Wait, is he trying to say that all that Ogerboy didn't say it
precisely that
What? These are his logs from the server. These are literally
his logs from the server. Hold on. Someone was spamming Hutch
killed his sister over and over. People were blaming me. Dot
dot dot. That's not you guys spamming LNL, is it? So, he literally
asked if people in that server were spamming live and learn.
And multiple people say no. Dude, you are a lying sack of [__]
Hutch. You are a totally despicable
fantastic [__] Oh, that one was close. Whoa, I almost
didn't make it. Jesus Christ, man. >> had like three people
immediately
>> is not
precisely what you said." I'm like, "I'm not doing it. It's not
any of us." And then that was it. >> Also not true.
Also not true. >> Wait, what's the what's the follow up
>> about this. I Wait, what's the follow up
Hold on. What What is the follow up there that that he's saying
also not true? That people didn't say it wasn't them? I I don't
know. Maybe he
He says he has a sleeping disorder. Maybe he doesn't mem- like
remember it. Uh none of that is true. None of that is true. And
by the time I looked back cuz I was on my phone, by the time
I looked back, they did they'd already banned the person and
it had stopped. Also not true. Everything about that is a lie.
He's talking about in live and learn chat. Does Does Ogerboy,
or sorry, does Hutch think that he's saying in the Snark Discord
or something? What's crazy is like he knows that I can see the
conversation. So, why why Why would you And I would just you
know, like why would you not assume like at some point this is
probably going to go up in the internet. You are just lying.
I'm just going to call him a liar right now cuz I By the way,
this is something I looked into that I like actually did some
searching for. It's I feel like it's almost impossible that I
would have missed somebody taking responsibility for this.
But I'm I'm asking somebody find me like a timestamp right now
so I can go look through my own logs and I'll see.
I will see. I will see.
But that's going to happen. So like why would you lie about this?
He's just like everything about that was a lie. So I've never
seen cuz it look if there's an opportunity to talk and and I'll
talk about this more in a minute because I don't think none of
these people understand the general vibe of like any of what
was happening.
I think people have a good idea
>> at this point of what was going on. Um, but like if
I'd seen anything like that where anyone was admitting to it,
like get the [__] out of here. There's no shot. There's
no shot I would have [__] tolerated that [__]
And then the other thing was Jason I This is >> so profoundly
dis- dishonest. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. What is this? >> I
think people have a good idea
at this point of what was going on. Um, but like if I'd seen
anything like that where anyone was admitting to it, like get
the [__] out of here. There's no shot. There's no
shot I would have [__] tolerated that [__]
And then the other thing was Jason I This is so profoundly dis-
dishonest, you guys. It'll all make sense at some >> I suppose,
but the levels of dishonesty going on here is like like astonishing.
We're not scared.
There's like That's like a four-parter thing, right? Like First
he says he comes in and and and like grills
the Discord. Like who's doing [clears throat] this? Didn't happen.
Then he says
nobody in the Discord No- Nobody in the Discord like identified
like who in the Discord had been doing the thing. Also not true.
Then he says he told him to knock it off. Not true. And then
then then here he says what did he just say? Jsal K like if I'd
seen anything like that where anyone was admitting to it, like
get the [__] out of here. There's no shot. There's
no profoundly
untrue.
That is like the biggest like untrue thing he said out of all
those things. It's just He's just lying. That is like the biggest
like untrue thing he said out of all those things. It's just
He's just lying. And you know, that makes sense because every
like every non-psychotic person on the internet recognizes that
invoking someone's dead family is just fully un- unhinged. It's
a level of escalation that is just so far beyond
what would be considered appropriate or
in this kind of a situation. People know that that's unhinged.
And you know, he knows that if he if you know if he >> spamming
your chat would obviously be unhinged. Yes.
But it's not I don't believe anybody spammed your chat, so. is
seen to have like stood by and did nothing when that kind of
stuff was going on, then that would reflect poorly on him because
it does. It does reflect poorly on him. If I was on if I was
in Discord in any kind of group
where something like that was happening,
I would be gone immediately. I would never I would never associate
with people who did stuff like that. Our friend Oh Did stuff
like what? Like spam that [__] in chats? This is
crazy, man. Your boy here here he made a different decision when
that whole thing went down. No shot I would have [__]
tolerated Oh, also
you're literally in you're literally in a community. You go on
a a stream where people do this. What do we talk about, man?
who did that [__] And then the other thing was Jsal
K made mention that
uh if he had seen anything about it, like that's something he
wasn't going to tolerate either. Like it's not like he was the
owner of the server, he's not into my knowledge. But that They're
all distancing themselves from but like the point is like that,
you know, was in keeping with the tone of the whole discord.
Like I they're they're trying to distance themselves
from this particular thing about my dead sister because it's
like just an an especially egregious example
of like how far gone these people were, but the tone of like
these kind of attacks was consistent throughout the whole thing.
Like that was the entire tone of The best part about this is
now people are very very very obviously saying they didn't do
it.
In the server, he's just lying.
And the best part is as I scroll through this everybody is saying
at the same time that he's a complete who can't follow an argument
or a conversation. So
Little little meta ironies in the chat.
Like this this can't follow No, no, we wouldn't do that. It's
somebody else. It's got to be somebody else. We would never do
that. Uh this can't even conversation. That was something that
would like get you banned for sure. Um but yeah, I don't it's
it's not What?
tolerate either. Like it's not like he was the owner of the server,
he's not into my knowledge. But that that was something that
would like get you banned for sure.
Nobody got banned for it. Nobody got banned for this. I don't
know what like I I don't know why he's lying about this. What
a crazy thing to lie about. Do these people have any [__]
Oh, Hutch thinks See, Hutch is a stupid. He can't tell that Oger
boy is saying the person got banned from Livin Lard's
Right? That's obviously what
That's obviously what Oger boy is saying that the person got
banned, right? into my knowledge. But that that was something
that would like get you banned for sure.
Nobody got banned for it. Nobody No, spamming your chat, you
stupid
That it's not okay to go spam in your chat. It's like find a
joke about anything in there, yeah. I have like I hadn't seen
anything like this, but I wouldn't ban somebody who said, "Oh,
we're making a desk and a hutch or sister." I wouldn't I wouldn't
want somebody banned who said that in there.
Sorry, you The fact that you lump it there in together just proves
that you can't follow conversation. That everything everybody
said about you, that you're a total who can't pay attention.
Yes, that's just true. But he got banned for this. I don't know
what like I I don't know why he's lying about this. What a crazy
thing to lie about. Do these people have any integrity? Like
an ounce of integrity. Well, yeah. Yeah, we would we would not
ban somebody for a joke in the server. I would go, "Hey, that's
weird. You're a weirdo." Right? But I I don't think people would
be banned for it. Yeah. I don't It's It's not coming To my knowledge,
it was Hey, there's got to be like four or five different logs
in that server of me going, "Hey, this is weirdo behavior. Hey,
this weirdo behavior."
It's me casting judgment on people, but I don't think principally
they shouldn't be allowed to say that's like crazy. You know
what I mean?
Realistically, by the way, that's they're saying it to themselves.
Like I I like people talking to themselves in the Discord or
times where I've said >> coming from anybody that I was
aware of. Just like bald-faced lie. Blatant lie. Like just unambiguous
lie. I find it very interesting
you know, a a few people
have been trying to like tar and feather
for the company I keep from time to
And they're in there sharing in a Discord not pushing back whatsoever.
Not true. Uh Completely not true. True. It is true.
Travacchio with $5. If any of these snarkers found you
There it is. It Wait, is he I'm sure somebody's pushed back on
the hutch sister thing. I know that literally it was pushed back
on when we had the vote thing that I showed yesterday.
But he's just lying. This will be a really interesting test to
see how effective these like open and obvious lies are.
If you're just trying to stay silent to see who's in the right,
like you should be asking for proof. If people want to want to
say this is happening, they're making claims, ask them for proof.
If you're just waiting back waiting holding back while these
people slander
I'm going to keep track.
Mostly without being able to do anything about it, but you know,
just in case you ever ask me to buy you a drink one day. Is it
an attempt to say anyone that mocks him for his relation to Destiny
is a hypocrite? Oh. Who was a doxer, it's crazy and hypocritical.
I would never in a thousand years ever be in a Discord like that.
Ever. Okay. Are you kidding me? I am an adult person, reasonably
well adjusted, I would say. Like I
I don't know what to say. Like I'm getting pretty close to crashing
out and I like
I Why would I do that? Why would I associate with like that level
of degeneracy?
That's not true. Also, it's not a cult, so it's a flippering,
but whatever. Uh when you had people bring up my deceased sister.
Uh paranoid
with the tier one membership. Thank you. It kind of makes sense
that they're trying to distance them themselves from it because
it's just like that's such a crazy thing to do, bro. It's a crazy
thing to do and it's a crazy thing to just like not like self-police
in the context of everybody else that was in the Discord, you
know, it just gives you a sense of like how they operated. Just
all the time, you know, and like talking about spam in chat.
Um that's interesting. That's an interesting situation there.
I hate political ideas. I hate being chicken [__]
I hate people that that I don't want anything uh to to happen
to these people. I don't want anybody to harass them. I argue
about things. I want to talk about why these people are full
of [__] I want to use them as object lesson to say
don't be like this person. But there's at no point in here have
I been like hit this person with any Like that's not that's never
the way that I have ever ever ever carried
So but he did this
He said got to say I'm not terribly surprised
to have found this in the Are you denying?
Like what what's what's what's your issue with cropping out the
name? Are you denying that it's real? Is that what you're denying?
I mean cuz you just talked about it for last like 10 minutes
uh seemingly acknowledging that it was real. The leaked snark
Discord logs. Folks, this is online politics. If you're invoking
dead family members over this stuff, you're years overdue for
extensive therapy. Delete your accounts and re-evaluate. Asmongold
is happy people getting fired. So if you said JD Vance Asmongold's
dead mom, Asmongold would defend it. Asmongold if his dead mom,
Asmongold blew up his mom.
Oh wait wait wait wait wait wait. Wait wait wait. A reminder
that Asmongold killed his mom by handing her a cigarette which
blew up her ventilator cinema. Asmongold seconds before pro clutching
over his dead mom. So you have Asmongold, he's supposed to have
a beautiful picture of his mom right before she set herself on
fire. Feels strong man.
This is your mom and Asmongold viewer
LOL cry about your dead dad some more Destiny. LOL cry about
your dead dad some more Asmongold Twitch version of Gerbils Destiny.
I don't want to offend him
by commenting on his mom.
Asmongold, how is your mom doing? Hey Asmongold, where's your
mom buddy?
Seems like this would be the community you wouldn't want to draw
from, right? Probably, if I had to guess.
Yeah, it's just it's weird for me, right? It's pretty weird that
Hutch would associate with people and communities that do this,
right? The creator who does this Destiny's done it directly.
No?
I I don't think it matters. Like I'm I think Hutch is Hutch is
fully aware of who Destiny is. Like all of that all of that that
he is everything he's calling out right now. He's fully aware
Dessy's like that and he just doesn't care. Right? He is He is
just lying about this to other people. He's just trying to get
in good with that audience. It's transparent. It's obvious. It's
sad.
So, they cut off whoever the [__] this was. Now,
could be anybody. If you were to put the name associated with
it, this is why this to me First of all, it would be a screen
name. Okay? It's not like it would be the real name of the person,
but it would be a screen name. If someone like that was doing
something like that, I think that there would probably be a level
of value in at least putting the screen name there. Because the
other part of this is going to be you want the people that own
the server to be able to go, "No, we saw that and we [__]
banned them." You want to be able to go, "That was a [__]
person. It was a shaky person on This just This is so far from
the truth. I don't know if he's diluted himself. Maybe he's memory
holed it because because of the shame and the guilt. Uh but this
is so far beyond the truth. >> whatever They were on thin
ice. We saw that they did this [__] and then we [__]
banned them. But you can't do that because you're not including
the name. I wouldn't mind admitting to this that I was behind
something like this, but this isn't what I do. I've never been
like this. When this [__] occurred,
I was telling them in the [__] in one of the in the
main channel. I'm like, To be clear, kind of wanted to [__]
with them a little bit, but if you guys are going to force my
hand on this, he's not the one who did that. Just to be clear.
He's not the one who did that. If I was giving off that impression,
that's not what I intended. But But everything he's saying is
so so far from the reality of how that all like went down. He's
just lying like lying about it like blatantly
lying about it. And get the [__] out of here. Like
you better not be one of you guys doing this cuz I was still
relatively new, but I was like, "No, [__] that."
That's one, but two, it's just weird. It's it's just so like
even more pathetic because it's like I don't I don't know. Is
he diluting himself? The levels of like patheticness just across
this whole everything that we've react to so far is just so profound,
but like now he's like crafting this head cannon where he like
stood up. You know, I was new to the group, but I spoke up anyways.
And it's just like none of it is true. None of that is true.
He's just lying about this, but is he Is he lying to himself?
Does he believe his own lies? Who knows? I have no idea. to me.
Like why would you not include
This right here would give the other people that were in there
or that might have been in there the ability to go, "No, no,
no. We complained about that person and they got banned." Like
I don't I don't I have faults with that I have issue with this.
A lot of slurs. He has issue with He has issue with this because
it
really reflects poorly on, you know, that that level of degeneracy
was going on and there was no policing of that of this of this
this particular thing. There was no policing of it at all. I
got to say a lot a lot of slurs. Like I mean slurs, you guys.
Uh the bad ones. Like the very very bad ones. Lot of slurs. Interesting.
Interesting about that. He's pretty quiet about that. Do you
actually care about slurs, Hutch? The guy who played Call of
Duty for so long, you care about slurs?
In a in an invite-only space, you care about slurs? Really? In
an invite-only space, you care about slurs? Why?
I just don't What is the virtue say? Why are you like virtue
signaling at slurs right now? Why would you pretend you care
about this? You can't possibly care about this. >> Of all
the people he you know, he he definitely You know, a lot of these
people are kind of like nihilists, you know? Like I don't know
if You get the sense Our chief complaint with you is that you
are a cynical defeated whiny weepy
How in the world are you arguing we're nihilistic?
that ideology is not the thing that's like driving these people
or even politics. Maybe it has like the facade of that, but really
it's about personal spite and whatever.
But him in particular, like he he definitely presents himself
as like this like Uber Uber woke person, right? Like Uber like
progressive person. Well, you know, Lonerbox
apparently had a little mole
in a secret snarker Discord with 100 plus people. I think it's
uh Is it a secret Discord if there's 100 people in it? We covered
the DGG big screen thing last Did you ever talk about it before?
They got exposed. Yes. We literally talked about it openly, said
obviously I'm in a clipping
like weeks ago.
Yep. Had no problem saying it. I'm just like, "Are you going
to tell me you don't have any Might have been reacting to Destiny.
Are you going to say you don't have any Discords like this?"
I'm like, "Bro, I got a clipping Discord. And I know that people
have been banned from that Discord and are really mad about it
and talk about it in other places. I'm not hiding it anywhere."
Yeah, we got a We got a clipping Discord. What's the problem?
What is the
>> Exposed. Did anyone publicly talk about it before it
got exposed? >> No, I mean I mean that's technically an
out in the open channel, but if nobody knows it's there, then
it's still a secret. It's still some place where hundreds, if
not thousands, of people snark on content creators at any given
moment. So like, I mean, you know, what are It's all It's all
Dude, that was a big face. That was a big set of faces. >> place
where hundreds, if not thousands, of people snark on content
creators
at any given moment.
I mean,
you know, what are
It's all It's all semantics.
Thousands? I don't know about that. Here's the other thing. They're
going to drip feed this It's the most obvious thing in the world
at this point. They're in as opposed to if Well, you know, kind
of make Uh Marmaduke and get $10 Oh, sorry. Marmaduke and SpaceGhost.
Thank you very much for the gifted subs, guys. Thank you, thank
you, thank you. >> Make sense. They wanted to say like
these people are [__] up and here you go. And Uh
Zixen and the Wixen with $2. Thanks for creating all this delicious
chaos. I didn't create this. I didn't create this. Don't rope
me into this. I did not consent to this. And then they would
just dump the whole thing online, call it a day. But they're
not going to do that. There's no There's no drama in that. There's
no They want to They want to drip drip drip. And then they also
want to be able to like selectively redact I know Why would the
fact that this is secret be scary? Isn't it the things that are
being said in there that are bad?
The fact that it's secret does nothing.
The fact that it's like invite-only does literally nothing. What
are we talking about? Some people are arguing now apparently
that the fact that it was secret is bad. What Why? No, I Oh,
yeah, he's got the logs, but he's Why do you think it's secret?
Oh, cuz it's like
cuz some of the people we're talking about have shown an open
propensity to dox anybody critical of them. Maybe that? Might
that be why it was secret in the first place? Why it was invite-only?
Because the people who get criticized, the same people who are
complaining about it now, are the same people that we were looking
to avoid the scrutiny of. We didn't want to get doxed by. What
do you think? He's not going to do it either. Oh, by the way,
I don't even know I don't think that's why it was made in the
first
But that's what it became very quickly. Right? I think when it
first I don't even know what it was meant to be when it like
when they first made it. I don't know what the thought was.
I actually have I don't know the history of the chat.
If this was an unhinged across-the-board situation, you would
just dump the whole thing. You would put it somewhere on a website
and just call it a day. >> You just said that there's like
a drip drip drip thing going on, right? Like And then people
could go and look and consider for themselves. The one of the
Hold on. We're not there yet. I want to let him talk for a little
bit more. And uh offered, you know, said I I could pay him $20,000
to get my hands on the logs, and I thought it was a fair deal.
So, you know what? Let's do it. There's no way There That has
to be a meme. That's the saddest thing in the world if he did
do that. I kind of feel like he probably is not joking, but I'm
just for sake of his The level of brain rot. own mental health
insanity, I really hope that he didn't Cuz LonerBox was saying
on his stream that somebody paid 20 grand, and he's admitting
to it.
Mhm, I think Loner Yeah, Ogre Boy probably misheard it, or maybe
didn't watch the whole clip. I think LonerBox was very obviously
joking when he said
Sometimes when I hold out hope on a human being, okay? That's
so That It had But it But it has to be. wonky, it has to be.
Jesus Christ. Because if he did pay that much money, first of
all, that means Loner hates him. Like that would mean Loners
Like Hutch is a joke to him. As opposed to being something that
they Like they they together, [laughter] they've collaborated
in the past. Just the really like particularly stupid attempt
at like sewing division. And Wait, wouldn't that you pay $20,000
for He's saying that Loner would obviously be an If you paid
If he made you pay $20,000 for it, he would like think you're
particularly stupid. Like He actually can't follow the conversation.
He doesn't even know what's being said. Oh, you said LonerBox
thinks I'm dumb. That's all that happened here. Like Yeah, again,
the Hutch RAM is just very, very compressed, okay? He's got like
4 kilobytes of RAM. So, if you talk long enough If you talk for
more than like 5 to 10 seconds at a time, he just Like he starts
to lose context in the conversation. He just can't maintain it
all at the same time. You're just You're overfilling the stack,
okay? Stack overflow. It's over. He's crashing. He's blue screened.
This is the most exciting thing that's happened to any of them
in a long time, and because of the This is 1,000% the most exciting
thing that's happened to him in probably years. way that they're
going to decide to release the information in maybe the weeks
and even months to come, they're going to be able to keep this
going forward. Who knows? I don't know. Who knows? You're not
going to be able to talk about him while he talks about his son,
cuz he's going to say, "Why are you making fun of a tiny little
creator like me?" He's going to be like, "I'm just a small being,
you guys. Why are you making fun of me, Jebediah Hutch?" Joseph
Jebediah Hutchinson, I understand, and I'm not sure I and the
one thing I was saying a lot in the early goings was like, I'm
not trying to yuck anybody's yum, okay? I'm not trying to do
that. I go, "But here's the thing, what you're doing isn't politics.
It's not. You're treating this like it's a reality TV show."
And that's kind of the way That's kind of the way a lot of the
people in there were doing it, right?
Oh my god.
The absolute sheer amount of projection on display. Any I think
like it for the I didn't What? Ogre Boy doesn't treat it like
a reality TV show. He is sincerely engaged. He sincerely watches
a lot of political stuff. He sincerely follows and reads a lot
of stuff. And then when he engages in conversations, he does
a little kayfabe cuz he's a wrestling fault like he's a wrestling
fan. He does a little kayfabe. He tries to ham it up for fun.
That's not a reality TV show. That's him like sincerely engaging
and then doing a performance. You can do both of those things
without it being reality TV, man. It was people treating it like
that, but it's also doing a lot of the [__] that
Sargon has talked about incessantly. It's using content creators
as the lens for politics.
Guys, guys, don't you realize? I'm just imagining him like lecturing.
Guys, don't you realize you're not actually doing politics? Don't
you know? But also, we're kind of using content creators as a
vehicle for politics. It's
I'm not that deep. Like you can do it. I'm guilty of it two times,
but that then why are you lecturing people about this? This guy
is like a caricature, man. That's all this ever was. So when
he's talking about this [__] hey, that thing that
you're doing, you can do it, but it doesn't matter. Nothing matters.
I don't matter. You can go volunteer at a soup kitchen instead.
Am I going to do that? No. Am I going to continue to argue with
you guys about the same thing? I can do the same thing that you're
doing exactly, like literally exactly. Yes, but let me just lecture
you about that real quick. This guy is insufferable. I want you
to think He's saying that it doesn't have an impact that he has
fun doing it. He enjoys it immensely, but that it's not having
the impact he that a lot of people think they're having. If you
think you're doing politics, that's one thing. But if you're
treating these No, you know what? We got to call him Ari Shaffir.
That's how we're going to get around his his searches of himself.
No more mention of Ogre Boy so he can't go to his website and
figure out when we talked about him. He's going to be Ari Shaffir
from now on.
Like even that even that just shows like a critical
lack of capacity. Like that is the level of intel Hutch when
he hears that there's a website where you can search transcripts,
he doesn't understand. He actually can't put these concepts together
that you would just be able to search a new word. Like he's not
intelligent enough to just bring that in automatically. He can't
like it just doesn't even register that that is like abstract
concepts. Oh, you have something where you can search and then
we're going to call him a different word than ogre boy. So when
he searches ogre boy, he won't find it anymore. But you just
said it in a video about ogre boy. Like what do you think the
odds are that ogre boy wouldn't see this? You've said yourself
you think he'll see this. So like somehow in his head that is
a website that lets you search for mentions of ogre boy. Like
he just doesn't nothing clicks in this dome of his. It's just
it's impenetrable. It's so thick it's impenetrable. These people
like they're they're reality TV characters now you're all like
oh This is actually even better point chat pity. He literally
said the ogre boy mention and Arya Stark within seconds of each
other. So they're going to be within the same time stamp in whatever
transcript there is. His website he also called it his website
too. It's this guy is kind of foundationally I wonder if any
of these DGGers like think about this. Like hey, dude this guy
like actually can't understand this at all. Like he's actually
really dumb. He doesn't get it. You're wasting your time. None
of this matters. I do it too. Just know that what you're doing
doesn't matter. But I but also I do it too. I know what I'm like
you know what is going on right now because it kind of involves
me in some respect and I know you you're going to ask me about
this [__] So I don't mind talking about it now that
the cat's out of the bag. But other than this, I've said if he's
talking about the DOJ I don't give a [__] If he's
talking about Trump, that's good. Talk about Trump. Talk about
Trump all day. If you want to talk about like do dumb content
about Hasan, I don't watch any dish content about Hasan. I don't
really give He watches He watches everything. Little Arya Stark
watches everything. When he's trying to defend what Kamala did,
Oh yes, especially watches it when he's covering Hasan drama.
Or when he's flying about Gaza. Then I get mad and I can't help
myself and I'm going to do exactly what we're doing right now.
But that's it. But outside of that, I don't give a They hit me
at a time when I'm like, "Oh, I'm looking for a new group of
people with when I'm not at [__] work." And then
this is what occurred. Straight up. Literally that's what happened.
Just the most believable thing he's ever said. Like everything
about that lines up. Yeah, that sounds about right. I got to
say, if I had to imagine what that trajectory looked like, definitely
looks like that. That was That was how I got in and that was
what I noticed. It's just reality TV shows. It is It's a lot
It's a lot to unpack. We're going to end it there. You know,
I just I just Let's just put a bow on that one. I don't know
Let's just put a perfect end to that one. I mean, just like very
rarely do you get such a insightful look into the
>> Boy, oh boy, oh boy, buddy. Boy, oh boy. There's like
if only only I could go into specifics.